well the pandemic financially impacted
countless number of people who lost
their jobs
and whose businesses were forced to
close but there was also plenty of
americans who were unaffected
financially by the pandemic kirsten
joyce joining us now with a new trend
we're seeing by those individuals well
denise and brian there is pent-up demand
to spend money to get revenge on the
pandemic
we caught up with a money-saving expert
on how to do so wisely
a lot of americans are feeling deprived
after being cooped up for a year due to
the pandemic
after not being able to take any
vacations for more than a year now
and being cooped up at home we're ready
to just get out there and
do it safely many haven't been able to
go out and spend their money
and they want to revenge spend according
to money-saving expert andre aurora
they kind of want to get some revenge on
the world
and reward themselves for all the
hardships they have endured this past
year
the national retail federation estimates
retail sales will increase between 6 and
a half to 8.2 percent this year
to a total of up to 4.4 trillion
exceeding the 4.4 percent average during
the previous
five years those consumers who plan to
revenge spend will do so on items like
luxury purses electronics clothing
and dream vacations my husband and i
actually just
booked a trip to napa for
early june just to get away the two of
us for a couple days i
love to buy clothes and so for about a
year
i wasn't going anywhere so there was no
reason to buy clothes and so
now that i'm back out and back in the
office meeting with people
i'm taking this time to you know find
lots of new clothes there are a lot of
people out there who would say
don't do it at all it's a waste of money
but warwick says it's okay to go back
out into your community and spend money
in fact it's helpful to small businesses
who have suffered the past
year just make sure you plan for it do
so wisely
by fitting it into your budget a budget
doesn't mean it's going to restrict how
you spend your money
it allows you to make thoughtful
spending decisions it allows you to
figure out
where you need to spend less so that you
could afford
these extra purchases these splurges
expenses you may have taken on during
the pandemic
extra streaming services online food
delivery or tutoring
you may no longer need and that can free
up some extra money for a
getaway with your kids you can swap kids
clothing on the swoondle society
and look for gently used items through
offrop or ebay
while you're at it sell items you no
longer need to pay for your revenge
purchases
optimize cash back on daily purchases by
using the right credit card
use those rewards to revenge spend
credit card matching apps like
gigapoints can help you find a credit
card that'll earn you the most money
cashback tools like scently and fetch
rewards will also help you earn money
back as well
one more thing you can also stretch your
revenge dollars by snagging daily deals
and using coupons remember groupon
living social
stores like costco offer additional
savings opportunities
where you can find deals on theme park
tickets and restaurant gift cards brah